-We're about to play charades.
You know the rules of charades.
Each player gets a turn giving
silent clues to their teammate.
-If I do this...
-Yes.
-...it means "Titanic."
-Okay, good. Done. Brilliant.
-30 seconds on the clock
per turn.
We'll do four rounds.
Then the fifth round
is a charades showdown.
Both teams give the same clue
at the same time.
I'll go first. You guys
can all take your seats.
-Okay.
-All right, partner,
you're over there.
-Amazing.
-Tariq, good luck to you, buddy.
-[ Laughs ]
-Guys, what number
shall I choose?
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
Wow. Just 2 or 3.
Interesting. I'll go with 2.
Okay. [ Clears throat ]
Okay.
-Okay.
-Yeah?
-Yeah.
-Okay, good.
Is that -- Songing?
Songing. Singing.
-Songing? Yes. Gosh.
-A song.
-Really good at this game, guys.
-We're off to great start.
All right. Here we go.
-It's a song.
Okay. Four words.
First word -- You.
I. Yes.
Second word...
Snug. Kiss.
I Kiss...
"I Kissed a Girl."
-Yes! That's it!
-Yay!
Yes! Whoo-hoo!
I just...in my eyes
and got it in there.
-Well done.
-Got it in there.
-Very good at this game.
-We got in there.
"I Kissed a Girl."
-Very good at this game.
-Early Katy Perry.
-Whoo-hoo!
-Early Katy Perry smash hit.
-Excellent.
-Smash hit record.
Oh, yeah! Probably went
platinum with that jam.
Anyways...
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
- I'm doing 5. I'm doing 5.
-Uh...
-[ Laughs ] Oh, no.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-All right.
Now, he fakes confidence,
but it's --
You can tell he's
trembling underneath.
-Song. Four words.
-"I Kissed a Girl."
-First word.
Roll. Roll. Roll.
Tumble. Roll. Spin.
Roll.
-Wow.
-Rolling?
"Rolling Down the River."
Second word.
"Rolling in the Deep."
-Whoa!
-Whoo!
-Wow. Wow!
You worked hard.
You work too hard, man.
-That was commitment.
-That is commitment.
-I remember last time we
played -- But Bomer's good.
Last time, who did we
play with, Matt?
-We played with Jessica Biel.
-Yes, and...?
-And you guys were stomping us
and squashing us.
And then I actually beat her
on "Cry Me a River" at the end.
-Ohh. That's right.
Her husband's own song.
-How are they doing, by the way?
-They are really --
They're fantastic.
They're fantastic. All right.
You're up, partner. Let's go.
Emilia, let's go for it.
We can do this.
Come on.
-We can do it.
-You got it, Emilia!
Come on!
-What one should I..?
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
3? 3. Okay.
[ Laughs ]
Okay!
-All right.
-Okay.
Okay.
-Okay!
All right, I don't what it is.
All right.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's a song.
-Yeah.
-Okay. It's four words.
First word.
-[ Blows ]
-Blow?
-[ Laughs ]
Um...
Uh, uh --
-Okay, okay, okay.
-Exhale. Puff.
-No. Yes!
-"Puff the Magic Dragon"?
-Yes!
♪♪♪♪
-Come on.
-I mean, what the...?
-You see the way it works?
That's like --
-Boom!
-Mental charades.
We don't have to do anything.
You just tell me
what song is four words.
"Puff the Magic Dragon."
Whoo!
-Excellent.
-Whoo!
-Wow.
-"Wow" is right.
-Very on topic for your show.
-The bar is here, FYI.
-What do we think, Tariq?
-Oh, man.
I really wanted 3.
Let's go 7. Let's go 7.
-7?
[ Exhales deeply ]
[ Laughs ]
All right. Okay.
Ready?
-Yeah.
Uh, song.
Marching.
Uh, march -- Little big man.
How many words is it?
How many words?
Okay. It's a marching song.
Uh...
Boyz II Men? Uh...
"Glory of the Angels"?
"When the Saints Go
Marching In."
Uh, march.
"Stairway to Heaven"?
-Yes!
♪♪♪♪
Thank you.
-What?! You got to be
kidding me, man! Oh, my God.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-It's levels.
-You wait until the last second.
"Stairway to Heaven."
That was fantastic. Well done.
All right. This last one.
This is the last round.
Matt and Emilia, you guys go.
And you both give the same clue
at the same time.
Whoever guesses it
wins the whole thing.
This is the tightest match
in the history of
"The Tonight Show."
-Professionals.
Professionals.
Okay. What are we doing?
-You were really rolling.
-You choose. You choose.
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
-10? 10?
-Yeah, why not?
All right. Here we go.
I'm not looking.
-Okay.
-Don't cheat, Tariq.
-Ooh, okay. Yeah, okay.
-I know.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Okay.
-How do we -- What do we --
We just do it at the same time?
-Yep.
-Ready?
-Oh, it's a movie. Go.
-Three words.
-Okay.
-"Titanic."
Oh, no. Throw up.
-Vomit. Vomit.
-Hurl. Hurl.
-Puke. Puke.
-Vomit. Sick.
-Second word.
-Big.
"The Big Sick"!
♪♪♪♪
-Aah! "The Big Sick"!
-So close! So close!
-"The Big Sick."
You are the champ.
-That was beautiful.
That was beautiful.
-The champs right there.
Matt Bomer, Tariq Trotter.
Emilia Clarke!